I start at 5:00 means how to start your
own self-driving car project and
everything of this with Python so and
the goal of my it yeah just a short
history so I presented this same talk I
believe a couple of months in the local
Python meetup and so today in this five
minutes I'd like to plant a simple idea
in your head that you can go put your
phone on your dashboard start recording
pictures and start recording videos and
like literally in one hour you can start
to engineer your self-driving algorithm
and you can contribute to this area so
and this driving shivnath out driving
shift knowledge it didn't start
yesterday so it started almost hundred
years ago so that's the picture of the
first radio-controlled car on the
streets of New York City in 1925 so you
probably surprised that it's so long
history and why we want self-driving
cars so the regular explanation here is
it we expect it will save lives and it
will make transportation better and
easily accessible more efficient more
reliable and more personalized so every
everybody probably has this problem like
you drive you to your work you're alone
in a car and then you take a trip you
with your family and you need a minivan
so you need different cars for different
purposes so the regular plot with levels
of automation so probably many people
have seen that it's quite popular over
the last few days so there are five
different levels of automation and what
we want with one full at a mission level
five and we are not there yet so like
Tesla or standard or other vehicles who
has some autonomous driving capabilities
there at level two and probably some
share of level three and four but mostly
at level two there are lots of companies
investing in this area right now so this
is list and there are
not all of them so it's always changing
moving so you will see new companies
come in some companies go and from this
list but that just demonstrate here how
many people companies work in this area
so this is very interesting and popular
and very very hot so who will be first
nobody knows so you can start coding
your own algorithm and probably you will
be the first who will make that level 5
autonomous car yeah so there is a survey
made by Lex Friedman he's giving a
course at MIT on self-driving cars so he
made this survey in a belief in his
Twitter and some people think it will be
Tesla some way more but that's I stole
this slide from him so he shows that
list so in 1998 that's the list of the
people of the companies working on a
search in Internet there is no Google so
and now Google dominates everything so
self-driving cars in Austin so just
recent report announced and announced
that they are coming to Austin so in
collaboration with our guy AI so you
will see more and more these vehicles
around the city so and at the same time
way more announced that they closed the
Parisian in Austin although nobody have
seen them for last few years here so
regulation in Texas in this area very
easy so comparing to other states we got
good laws related to autonomous cars so
the requirements are very simple so you
have to comply with all traffic laws you
have to be equipped with video recording
device so in case of some problems so
there is a history saved and you have to
be insured like a regular car and the
this law is so I learned that myself
that it prohibits local governments to
regulate self-driving vehicles and
innovation so the local community can
not prohibit you to drive
your autonomous vehicle in the community
and because my time is almost over so
that's the main topic that I'd like to
bring to you so there are lots of public
data at least these two companies
nuisance and Agra viewers they recently
released open data so it's labeled data
that you can start using for your
development and so if you want you can
make a picture or maybe I will share
these slides later so that's the code
everything written in Python so and data
is available and there are two papers
where you can find all details so and
that's very rich data collected in
different cities around the world and
you can start analyzing them and all the
data is labeled like you see there is a
label box around that car label around
people so that's the data that you can
start using today to develop yourself
driving algorithm thank you talk here
about one project that I have been
excited about for a long time actually I
first started working on the project
Euler back in I think 2005 or 6 when I
first started to learn Python
programming and who in the audience is
actually aware of project Euler oh so
one fifth so it's this website and you
can create an account and sign in and
they have these math problems and some
of them are very interesting and I've
learned a lot of very cool dynamic
programming techniques
Oh somehow it kicked me out to sign in
again so these the this is the progress
I have made back in 2007 I had all the
first 150 - problem solved and only a
few months ago I started looking at the
project again and they have almost 700
problems now and I looked at a couple of
them they're actually much harder
most of them than what they used used to
be and I found this very interesting
problem that want to share that so it's
a lot of fun if you want to learn about
programming techniques and whenever you
actually solve a problem you can then go
into the discussion forum for that
problem and look at the solutions that
all the different people have come up
with okay thank you very much okay well
hi when I signed up for the lightning
talk today there were I didn't really I
had one thing definitely I wanted to
talk about cuz I'm here with open teams
but I had a bit of a dilemma I mean this
is an open source conference talking
about technical topics and I've got my
own little small open source project
that I've been working on here and there
and I kind of wanted to talk about that
too
so I was a bit torn and I ultimately
settled on I want to talk about the open
source project so this open source
project though is related to a question
it turned out did I ask myself recently
I was I was trying to figure out you
know if I wanted to write code on
phone how could I do that you know and
that got me thinking more about what are
the limitations like what what what
would make writing code on my phone
difficult has anybody got any ideas
keyboard writte what else what about the
keyboard like cell the characters uh
what else would make it difficult to
write code on my phone no escape an
escape key well I'd have to say too much
right like if I talk to you person to
person
what makes that actually work context we
share information we can assume things
that that are shared between us so what
if I want to have a conversation with my
phone that ends up resulting in an
application like could I actually make
that work well it turned out asking that
myself that question I've been working
on this little open-source project on my
own by myself for a while and I realized
that was the answer so first off context
makes conversations work and now for a
brief demo so if we look over here I
want to write code here we go I want to
be able to write code that kind of looks
like this for testing purposes right and
I want to be able to say given some
condition when I do something then the
expected outcomes this other thing now
the problem with this code of course is
that well first off like how does result
is know that the value current value is
43 and how does value Plus know that
what I said before was 42 right how do I
pass that information around and even
then like if let's say I could actually
pass things around this way how do I
type check any of this right how do I
know if the preconditions for value plus
+ result is are satisfied well I thought
about that a little bit and I'd used a
few libraries I don't know if anyone's
familiar with cucumber but cucumber
takes an approach where you build up
these steps right and the steps will
move data in and they do with this
blackboard pattern of passing the data
around but it always bothered me that
that they lose the typing information
and they don't exploit the directed
graph that results from composing the
steps so what I've done right now is
made it so there's a way in Python to
say I've got this data that's going to
be shared between steps
within some execution context and
providing the typing information and
I've actually made this work you can
actually run this test that I just
showed you today what comes next is the
type checking which I haven't done yet
so I'm gonna issue a call today to say
you know I'd love help I'm gonna be
implementing the mypie type extension at
some point so you can actually know will
this test run and does it is it type
safe so I named it ll step originally
and and I called it at this is like
little logical steps and I was having
trouble coming up with a name I couldn't
figure out what I wanted to call it and
I've decided I really hate this name his
name is still boring right and it
doesn't really make sense so I started
asking myself what is a little step or
what is this project
well I'm focused on a typesafe
composition of steps it's a safety dance
so I'm gonna rename it safety dance but
that brings me back to that dilemma or
earlier which is that I had these two
things I wanted to talk about right
co-founder of open teams and I want to
talk about that maybe I'm not just a
co-founder maybe I'm a customer - so
we've got ll step here on open teams but
I'm gonna rename it so let's rename it
and so is you'd that call for
participation earlier asking folks to
help me with type checking I will
recognize you on open teams if you if
you contribute code issue a pull request
so to summarize create your open teams
profile sign up I guarantee you're gonna
like the way you look thank you I don't
have slides so I'll just have to use me
I guess as the entertainment here my
name's Roy Keyes I'm the head of data
science at a company called arundo in
Houston and I'm gonna talk a little bit
about how we hire data scientists so you
you may have heard that you know there's
sort of a scarcity of data scientists
from the data science hiring side of
things there is a glut of data
scientists so we have a very different
problem and maybe a view on that issue
quickly for some context we build we're
a small relatively small company
building software for industrial
customers powered by data science
whatever that means and we are
relatively unknown probably none of you
have ever heard of us before this but we
still get a ton of applicants for our
positions so typically we get you know
500 or more applicants for a single
opening for data science and and that's
that sort of the situation we're faced
with every time we hire so basically I'm
basic misses there there is a ton of
data scientists out there most of them
are aspiring data scientists you see
sort of a power-law distribution of
their experience and that's one of the
things that that we're trying to
overcome with our process so we we want
to have a efficient effective fast and
fair process to hire people let's see if
I have minutes here
and what that largely means is that we
want to spend sort of an inversely
proportional amount of time on a
candidate depending on what stage of the
process they're in we want to spend a
very small amount of time on a on an
early stage candidate but we're willing
to spend a lot of time on a late stage
candidate that we think is there's a
pretty good chance we might make them an
offer so the way we're currently doing
that and this has evolved over the last
few years of hiring is the first thing
the very first stage when we hire people
is we basically send almost everyone to
an online skills assessment so at that
point we may not have even looked at
their resume and there's a there's a
couple reasons we do this one is that
that just makes it very low touch low
effort for us but also we think that's a
lot fairer to do it that way
so the before we're looking at anything
you know did they go to you know
Hogwarts or whatever or did they go to
the Community Wizarding school you know
we we're not we're not screening at that
point we're gonna send them to a test
that's that's of basic data science
skills the other thing is that that
assessment that we give them part of it
is automatically scored so the first
thing then the next part is we look did
they pass the threshold for the
automatic scoring and then the next
thing is we're gonna move to if they
pass that threshold we look at a written
part of the test and that we have one of
the data scientists follow a rubric and
score then after that we go to and the
HR takes over the next step where they
do a phone screen they'll look at the
resume a little bit to see if there's a
you know sometimes we'll get people that
have a very unusual background and then
they might ask them some specific
questions there but generally they're
they're gonna do a check of can this
person legally work for us do they
understand that you know where we are
and some of the basic things that we
think about and then after that we do a
data science phone screen with a senior
data scientist and then eventually an
on-site and we go from there and so far
that has been pretty successful we've
gotten some really great data scientists
out of this process and then the only
other tip I'll add to this and is that
you should aggressively try to recruit
people to get into this pipeline
first place especially if you're trying
to specific go after specific groups of
people so that's very my lightning talk
on hiring data scientists and I'll be
free answer questions if anyone has them
hello everyone can you hear me yep okay
so yeah my name is Alejandra primera so
my background actually petroleum
engineer with about 15 years of
experience in the oil and gas industry
so you may ask yourself what is this guy
doing here so six years ago I started a
consultancy firm back in London where we
were tackling a problems of reservoir
engineering like building numerical
models and analytical models for four
different clients and we use a lot of
proprietary applications to to solve
those problems so I ended up having a
bunch of projects with a bunch of people
that were not able to actually share the
data or the knowledge among them so in
the past I used to have a stack of
applications that I used to use and I
started calling a basically in c-sharp I
moved to R and I'm happy to say that a
year ago I moved to almost completely to
to Python without leaving some stuff in
the back but what I want to talk today
it's the experience around that we have
at the moment building a web platform
for these needs to actually satisfy the
needs of consulting and actually
providing some information of the
Preseli executing for clients so anyone
here using the angle by any chance
and what about view for front-end
awesome so I'm going to talk to you
later on so I'm actually looking for for
input here as well and so the platform
that we have built so far it's pretty
much a web application where we're
building up a bunch of modules to solve
some of the stuff that we have already
done in the past so we are reviewing
projects and we are implementing
applications based on the projects and
data that we have executed most of a
pro-x our analytical projects some are
in numerical projects but basically we
have we are at the moment only two
developers and what I found is a lot of
it patrolling engineers that work with
me in the past
they don't like coding
at all so I'm kind of a hot one out but
I found another friend of mine that that
it's very helpful and we are actually
building this whole platform it's a
younger web framework where basically we
are using a cloud hosted application for
multiple users we have a database
impulse quest and basically most of a
templates and application the front-end
we are serving it with the angle the
angle templates we are using a bit of -
Claude Lee and on the other hand at the
very top we are also using a bit of
jQuery and JavaScript so this is a bit
challenging at the moment because we are
growing and we want to do we want to
have - we want to have interactivity in
the application but we don't want to
lose all the the benefits at the angle
bringers like the forms the the tables
and so so we want to still retain those
and we also have faced some issues with
the with some of our new dashboards and
when I started doing front-end
development
I found myself hating a lot a JavaScript
in particular so just show you very
quickly what we have so this is very
nice
I can build up applications pretty much
in half a day from scratch and view some
of the data are having the database but
at the same time when things get
complicated with forms and so on I'm
finding more and more difficult to use
the angle and Python and another thing
that out of the angle that we use it's
the rest framework however we are also
finding that writing a lot of this API
sits quite quite complex and it's we're
finding some issues so I'm gonna show
you some of the stuff that we we do and
interactivity for instance we want to
have pretty pretty responsive
application I don't want to go and click
around to execute a job as a query and
go back to the to the backend and bring
some data to a front-end I certainly
don't want to do that and on the other
hand this is a - blood leap
application that we have in place and
the issue that we have is that when we
go and change data we are really facing
a lot of a performance issues it's
taking as you can see probably two or
three seconds yeah doesn't look bad but
it's a it's an issue for us so we move
completely or we are moving some parts
of the application to to view basically
it's it's at the moment looking like
this oops
so we have now part of the application
in view and we are using a data storage
we are using a data storage in view
where we can map the whole state of the
application
what I found with view is that because
it's so strict in the way that I have to
code I'm really liking more JavaScript I
know exactly where the code is is placed
I can write my methods and for every
components and template so they styling
us home so my time is up but if you want
to chat with me we can we can have a
chat later thank you
[Applause]
okay can you hear me
okay good hey my name's Chris currently
I'm a bi analyst over at Keller Williams
and currently I'm also a student at the
UT data analytics and visualization
bootcamp and so here I'm gonna present a
recent project that me in my group
recently finished that uses that uses a
lot of open source technology to create
a full stack application of website that
that basically our theme was because we
you can see it around Halloween we
decided okay let's pretend to be pirates
for a little bit and so we're so a group
of high tech pirates that use data to
determine okay where are the best places
for lots of toys for a swab and so we
just recreate an application that uses
you know a lot of different tools in the
backend we use a post critical database
that will restore restore data and and
we pipe in which we store an app and
that we pipe using the Python flask
flask framework to be would produces
website real quickly about the data it's
the only a few minutes basically this is
what the pipeline looks like we have
budget area that we collected from
multiple sources and in un the World
Bank and the World Bank and a report
that is released by MasterCard every
year I've got the global destination
cities index that reports the cities the
highest number of tourists and also the
cities who spent them all with the toys
who spent the most money there and we
also placed and included a lot of
population data as well now if the
population data that one was a little
bit tricky because with certain
countries like the US you only have a
population every ten years for instance
right it's time it's not measured every
year but we decided to just do a simple
interpolation technique to estimate
the years in between what we were
targeting which we were two years 2011
to 2018 and you know you know we kept it
in the post great secret database which
we host you know Roku piped over to
flask and create this website which I'm
about to show you series of websites it
was created using HTML CSS and
JavaScript it's it's really nice and
really kept a pirate theme up pretty
much consistently throughout the entire
website and my teammates Nathan did a
really good job top of this so I really
would like to thank him for that I mean
with each tap here we have different
views of the data for example we have
maps that we created in tableau and
hosted and put it up on the website
using the tableau JavaScript API for
instance this one here which shows the
tourist and expenses and the city by
sitting in this map and you'll see what
this map is also pirate-themed because
we use the map box api which has a
pirate skin on it because why not
different views in conclude by country
was also included in one of our data
sets so we should also be able to show
that as well showing different patterns
in the data
yeah most popular tourist destinations
year every year just a simple graph in
tableau that we showed here wouldn't and
that you can filter by year to include
each year and the cities here here on
the right and we also included
information from a report cut award
happiness report I can hit the yearly
report to see if there's any you know
interesting correlations for example the
correlation between happiness and other
factors
this one happiness in freedom not that
highly correlated but happiness in well
GDP money that was much more strongly
correlated so if tap so tableau you can
create a lot of different visualizations
but sometimes you don't have as much
control of it right so another
view that we did was using a library
called d3
it's a it's a JavaScript visualization
library so and with this visualization
library we would create this bump choice
to view rankings because in this view I
don't really care you know about their
my total number of tourists so much
every single year I just want to see
like how they rank for example London
gets at the top spot quite a few times a
couple of times but Bangkok it's there
like it goes up there a lot and tourism
expense ranking theta is a little weird
something could be investigated but
Dubai takes the top spot every for
almost all yours tourism density which
are with how many tourists are there per
location here Amsterdam takes up the top
spot for quite a number of years then
suddenly drops off and is replaced by
Phuket and if I wanted to see more
detail I'll go to this tableau because
visualization down here and see that Oh
for Phuket for every local population
there are 23 tourists there which is
really overpopulated yeah and thank you
so much
[Applause]
hey thanks
my name is Brennan Collins thanks to all
of num focus and all the folks
organizing PI data I'm talking a little
bit today about some recent
contributions to data shader so there's
been a bunch of really interesting
developments in datasheet or data shader
is a general rasterization pipeline so
you can take large amounts of data say a
large data frame and you can create an
image out of it and you can see certain
structure out of big data and that's
what the raster format will give to you
but so that over the last couple of
months some of the highlights and data
shader include GPU support that came
that was merged and released yesterday
so some things check out there also
polygons support for data shader is is
coming very soon I specifically was
focusing on geo tools for data shaders
so I'm going to demonstrate some of the
geo tools that are available inside of
them data shader and specifically inside
of the user guide
so these geo tools you can think of
these as as raster tools and to show and
demonstrate some of the tools I'm going
to start by generating a terrain here
and I'm using Perlin noise to to start
to grab some data and start looking at
some of these tools so the hillshade
tool will you to illuminate a surface so
you can decide on an altitude for a
light source and a direction and then
you can take a surface and illuminate it
so here we're taking a what is Perlin
noise and pretending that that's
elevation data and then projecting light
on top of that surface data shader has a
lot of tools in it I'm specifically just
talking geo because those are the tools
that I tend to work on but there's a lot
to explore in data shader slopes so I'm
looking at at certain at terrain again
and looking at the the slope of the
surface aspect recently also came out
which is the downward direction of the
slope that's measured income
degrees NDVI so doing vegetation
detection on satellite data so we have
an NDVI function inside of data shader
now
bump mapping which is a cartographic
technique that can be used for putting
things like trees on top of the surface
so here let's run some bump mapping here
and if it comes out you can kind of see
now that terrain has has these little
green bumps that could be used for a
cartographic technique for representing
trees mean convolution filters that can
be helpful for different cartographic
techniques but is certainly more general
than spatial and here we're putting
together a full scene just based on some
data shader processing tools which
include like a coastal vignette and
trees and elevation and illumination we
also added a proximity tool and so this
proximity tool will allow you to take
any data shader aggregate and generate a
proximity aggregate based on that so
this would be showing each the distance
from any of the features in your
aggregate as a surface and that works
with any of the data shader aggregates
so here's an example of doing proximity
off of a line we also now support view
shed view shed is the idea of what can I
see from a specific location so if you
were on this terrain and so here we're
trying to look at what pixels would be
visible from an observer to a specific
target observer is a specific elevation
above the surface and then taargus are
different elevations and is essentially
if we could connect any pixels in the
image in a straight line without passing
through any other pixels would be the
definition of view shed and then we also
have a zonal statistics tool now which
will allow you to do summary stats on
zones inside of your images so that's
all part of the geography notebook
inside of data shaders so if you go to
data shader and sorry there's a little
small but if you go to examples and then
go to user guide then you can find a
bunch of these helpful notebooks here
with examples of how to get started in
data shader including this geography
thank you highlight one from
I talked about the open-source package
on anomaly detection early they start no
on track three bills by my team and this
is another open-source package which
recently also release the car TSR gate
is package to do data commutation on
time series data if you're working on
deep learning stuff for image you
probably pretty familiar with all those
idea of data documentation you have an
image of a cat and then you stretch it
you flip it you add noise to it you zoom
in zoom out crop and then you suddenly
have ten times of cat image and when my
team working the time series tasks using
deep learning we thought we can find
something similar and just use it but
surprisingly we couldn't find a very
good one online there's a cup of them
but not really well maintained so well I
could
this is not something very hard to do so
we just create by ourself and open
source this very lightweight package and
so basically we implement I think 15 of
different kind of augmentation method
and for each of them what you can do it
that you improve a bunch of time serious
work number this one with segmentation
labels and you pick one of the
augmentation method and you apply to it
for example one of the very common one
is random time warping so I randomly
warp the timeline of this treat time
series and I got three new version of
this thing and you can do this many
times so that you get a moderator and
your mother is more robust and of course
in practice you don't really only need
one augmentation you need you may need
to apply different kind of augmentation
better at the same time so in this
package we provide the API with operator
Plus this person which basically say
connect this augmentation with this and
then you do this and then you do this
then you can just call this entire thing
one time that run and you gave ax and y
and you Ockman Tate it's one by one
and sometimes we also realize that you
may need something like this so for the
first segment ation I want to do it I
say ten times in parallel so that
instead of a one-to-one augmentation I'm
doing a one to ten accommodation and in
the second one I want to do time five so
instead of have ten different versions I
have 50 different versions right so we
do we introduce this times signs to to
do this and sometimes we also realize
that the people may need to use
something like I don't really want to
add cheetah noise all the time I only
want to add it like 50 percent of time
randomly so we have this sign at if you
do at top five then that means that this
thing will only be run the 50% of our
time randomly and so if we apply this to
the original three time series we'll
look at something like this right
immediately your training set is more
robust and you can hopefully build a
better model if you know how to do that
and of course things can be incomplete
too complicated that you don't even know
what your pipeline looks like so we have
this summary to summarize what your
pipeline looks like this is basically
very similar to what you have in Cara's
if you use Cara's yeah so we open-source
this thing like basically saying Hamas
attk which is a package on Tuesday
afternoon and I thought this thing could
be more interesting to people because
this is about deep learning and you know
there's a - t Pony of course and but
surprisingly the other package get like
three hundred twelve stars within one
ounce but this one only got like 60 or
something and I feel this is a little
bit underrated if it's not the other one
get overrated so I want to give a
promotion to this thing again and if
you're doing time serious deep learning
try this thing and you can also well
also welcome you to contribute if you
see anything thank you
hello my name is Liliana Torres and I'm
part of the organization women who code
and recently this year we open a new
track that is called women who call
Python and first I want to thank and non
focus because thanks to them I'm here
today and they give me an ecology
diversity accepted and I'm here because
of that and I want to let everyone know
that this organization is working
globally and we're trying to encourage
more women to learn and to move in the
IT careers and we also want to make sure
that everyone knows that you are all
welcome to join us as long as you you
want to support that that opportunity
for women to grow and help them we're
always looking for speakers to help us
online to to teach this community with
the way different times of the day and
we are growing and we hope that some of
you can support us and if you would like
to talk more about it we can discuss it
later
again thank you so Josh shreds and I are
working on a project about unit
standardizations you need to measure
sensation however this is not why I'm
giving you this and this little
lightning talk if you go up you'll see a
poster but not the ones you used to
seeing a big poster it's an interactive
poster it's set up like this how many of
you have ever seen people going revolts
of large tubes on airplanes trying to
get to their conference many how many of
you have actually presented posters in
those conferences okay this is a
computer science conference you don't
see those but then you go to biology you
go to medicine you see hundreds of those
posters each one the cost cost about
hundred dollars to print here's the
picture for me from the NIH the poster
next to me probably costs $100 to print
today that I can get
machine unless the hundred dollars and
then I can present a poster like this on
it and the setup you'll see upstairs
tomorrow so you no longer need to
present the paper printer paper think
about those 80 posters or 100 posters
out there not having to be printed think
about only the save saving that money
and I'm not talking about the hassle of
actually going and printing up and
taking and carrying the chip on the
airplane and then figuring out what to
do the poster afterwards because you now
have it electronic form in electronic
form you can do other things you can
show pictures and talk about whatever
you wanted to talk you can have links
that if you click on all of a sudden
things will appear to whoever you're
trying to explain I'm talking about some
machine learning issues so I can
actually show this and I'm able to do
this just because the Pythons theme or
the whole of Western was able to create
those tools for me what you see here is
it actually a static HTML page whatever
is dynamic is already embedded inside
it's like a document you can send it to
people or you could give them the link
on the Internet and then later can
download it you can do things like
saying okay here's the zoom out problem
of what I'm talking about and this is a
machine learning power I'm showing
lexical proximity you can actually see
what proximity is between two units but
then I can show them oh no this is how
it really looks like this is a 25,000 by
25,000 approximately size matrix you
cannot even think about that size but
pirates can actually show it and you can
explore how it looks like but then I can
show it to you before machine learning
after machine learning and you can see
the difference and all of this can be
done in one poster you cannot so show it
on paper easily you can have papers
explaining your processes
it's our tables explaining your
processes that you use you can show
results of multiple neural networks and
show how accurate they are so this is
supervised learning and you can show it
Oh once I did it with this type of
architecture that type and you can see
how it changes and you can explore
deeper deeper and deeper all of those
things are possible using
five is to specifically Hall of use the
envelope what you see is panel panel
allows me to do those switches this is
specifically the plots our hall of use
and for those you who know it wraps
bouquet matplotlib and for those who
doing it while doing machine learning
many many people tell you machine
learning well it's like a black box you
can't look inside the neural network oh
yes you can look at this this is a
neural network during training and using
pi vis tools specifically hall of use on
top of data shader we can actually see
how a specific neural unit within the
neural network changes through time this
is time those are the new on units and
you can do this for different types of
parameters within one layer you can show
multiple layers in this way and this is
how you can explore all of your results
to summarize I use pirates tools to show
this if you interested in learning more
about the project come tomorrow and the
poster will be out there but you can
download it now it's on the web it's one
the one one document and of course you
can add in whatever links to whatever
publications you had before all of this
loop is actually static but it is
dynamic when you actually go and hover
things over it so stop printing paper
start using pirates
[Applause]